في اخر التطورات الميدانيه التي تم
تسجيلها خلال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره في
اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اليوم انها قواتها سيطرت على مرتفعات
وخطوط اماميه جديده في محور دوناتسك كما
قامت بتنفيذ هجمات جويه ثلاثه انفجارات في
كريبوي صاحباتها عمليات محدوده على خط
سفياتو وايضا ضربات جويه في نقاط اخرى
بالمنطقه كما تقوم القوات الروسيه بتوسيع
التحصينات الدفاعيه على ضفه اليسرى لنهر
دانيبر في منطقه خرسون
واشارتنا انه كما تحقيقه تقدم في محوري
بينما دمرت غاره جويه روسيه خزانه للنفط
قربه مقاطعه حركات
وعن خسائر 300 يوم من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كشفت كياف عن دمار كبير سببه
القصف الروسي المتواصل على البنى التحتيه
في البلاد حيث قالت بان روسيا او ان روسيا
اطلقت 4700 صاروخا على اوكرانيا وبان نحو
79% عفوا 97% من الاهداف التي
استهدفها الجيش الروسي كانت مدنيه وفقا
لوزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه كما اعلنت
الحكومه الاوكرانيه في ذات السياق عن
تسجيل
54,000,898 جريمه حرب وعدوان وتدمير نحو
114 مرفقا صحيا منذ بدايه الحرب
وتسببت الضربات التي تقول اوكرانيا انها
تستهدف المدنيين بشكل واضح في قطع امدادات
الكهرباء والمياه بصوره متكرره في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه